gut ich bin grüße zur heutigen sitzung
das ist die vorletzte sitzung diesem
semester von diesem experiment wird das
auch wieder digitalität heutige sitzung
vor der sitzung ist dem thema tätiger
digitalität gewidmet das ist ein thema
was in der regel besonders relevant ist
ich mache das gerne setzen
[Musik]
also das thema ist sehr zentral es ist
man auch dasjenige thema was die leute
vor allem interessiert wenn es über
digitalisierung werden häufig wird
digitalisierung und philosophie
reduziert auf die frage nach der
ethischen dimension und auch häufig
reduziert auf die dimension der
künstlichen intelligenz das halte ich
für verkürzt das halte ich für nicht
entscheiden oder nicht für
ausschließlich ich glaube es gibt ganz
wie der andere dimensionen dieser
problematik und kriegen können wir nur
dann erkennen wenn wir digitalisierung
von digitalität unterscheiden also wenn
wir verstehen dass digitalisierung in
einem technische angelegenheit ist und
dass digitalität eine kulturelle
dimension hat und eine ganz neue
realität erzeugt wir haben uns in diesen
neuen realitäten bereits in der letzten
sitzung ausführlich befasst
wir sollten in meinen augen eine these
die ganzen ethischen unserer
intervention nicht nur auf technische
und technologische risiken einer nicht
glauben neuen sphäre betrachten also
damit möchte ich sagen die digitalen
technik braucht digitale strukturen
weiter gefasst sind so eingedrungen
unseren alltag sind verboten mit unserer
existenz weise so dass es nicht mehr nur
technik nennen könnte eine kultur natur
und technik verschmelzen jetzt etwas
neuem ich glaube ich glaube dass man das
nebenan diesen drei kategorien die ich
ihnen schon mehrmals hier präsentiert
hat
besonders gut verstehen können die
lungen des raumes die logik den zeit
später wurde aber natürlich auch so was
eine neue form von gegenständlich
das eben alles im bereich der
digitalität hier die beziehung der
gegenständlichkeit hat objektivität wir
selbst auch ich glaube nicht dass das
eine ethische unbedingt vergeben
ständigen für uns im negativen sinne
bedeutet wie man eher sagen kann dass
man menschen nicht als lose gegenstände
im handel zeigt dass das nicht gemeint
ist sind dass es neue chancen ermöglicht
und ich glaube ich eben das komplementär
dazu in einer gegenbewegung dazu zu
diesem objektivierung eben auch alles
subjektiv wird in dem sinn dass gedanken
die vormals biermann und andere siedlung
war das intranet könnte man auch sagen
dass diese gedanken die privatheit auch
subjektivität als die ihm nach außen
gekehrt wird und die tendenz befördert
vom internet zum internet zu gehen ich
glaube dass das entscheidendes merkmal
der digitalität ist von abgekapselten
systemen in seiner person und seiner
vernetzung zu einer verbindung mit
ermöglicht ich glaube dass deshalb
depression so ein grundzug der sphäre
der digitalität ist also für italien
während meine these sie sehen alle set
mit einer zusammen und heute geht es
eben um die vitalität kleinen formaten
auch für diejenigen die zu schauen
nächsten freitag die letzte sitzung der
vierzehnte sitzung mit ausfällt weil ich
beruflich dort nicht in münchen sein
werde aber wir haben ein ersatz sitzung
jetzt am kommenden montag und der 2
juli von 16 bis 18 uhr raum bremen 214
und von 18 bis 20 uhr eine übung wo wir
auch noch dinge weiter diskutieren kann
in der letzten sitzung hatten wir uns
dem thema ontologie der digitalität
gewidmet ich habe gesehen ich habe noch
gar keinen like geben
das mache ich jetzt heute mal nicht als
wir hatten uns mit der ontologie der
digitalität befasst und das ist wie ich
glaube das zentrale thema also die frage
ins tv unterscheiden sich physikalische
und virtuelle gegenstände
wir sind letzte sitzung nicht besonders
die frage nach virtuelle handlungen
eingegangen sie erinnert sich der autor
dieses aufsatzes hatte erwogen dass eine
virtuelle beleidigung auch eine wird
eine wirkliche belastung ist also wenn
ich in computerspielen und man anderen
beleidige beleidige ich ihn nicht von
angesicht zu angesicht beleidigt ihnen
auch nicht verbal geleiteten meisten
schriftlich aber es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten die man würdet ihr wie man
virtuell in beleidigung realisieren
das sollten wir heute noch ein bisschen
verdienen als wir haben konnten bisher
nur konzentriert auf virtuelle objekte
eigentlich
und wir sollten uns auch mit virtuellen
handlung beschäftigt virtuelle objekte
da war die frage wie existieren sie eine
zeit wo diese frage stellt sich auch bei
virtuellen verhandlungen ist bei
virtuellen handlungen geht es dann gegen
ziele und die verfolgung von ziel- und
lars ricken und natürlich hängt die
frage nach virtuellen handlung auch mit
virtuellen objekten zusammen weil es
anders gesagt wie gehen wir virtuell mit
virtuellen objekten um also was können
wir mit virtuellen objekten tun und das
werde die frage die virtuelle handlung
wäre wie gesagt eine virtuelle
beleidigen aber ich denke eben auch
virtuelles wenn wir spiele gegeneinander
spielen dann denke ich ist es auch etwas
entscheiden virtuellen handlung eine
veränderte raum zeitliche logik also
damit möchte ich sagen die fehlende
reibung von der soziologischen die die
info sphäre ausgerechnet also nicht mehr
die geburt
das material ist das heißt wir haben
viel mehr unmittelbarkeit dort im spiel
und weniger reibung das wäre es ein
ansatz
wir hatten noch eine frage nach diesen
termin schon hatten wir schon wie wie
können wir es zu erkennen
besonders eine spannende frage und eben
wie sie im auto zeit existieren die
autor dieses aufsatzes den wir gelesen
hatten
das war meine entscheidung die können
wir dann springen der autor dessen
aufsatz von den drei oder vier
aussprechen der hatte wie wir gesehen
haben oder vielleicht noch sehen werden
unterschieden zwischen digitalen
objekten und sie auch oder
physikalischen objekten physikalischen
phänomenen phänomen meinte er so was die
blitz oder wie ein akustisches signal
meint der physikalische objekte können
wir digitalen nicht realisieren oder
virtuellen realisieren aber der können
physikalische phänomene digital
realisierung ich stelle die frage ist es
nicht darum den
ideale simulation also er brachte hielt
verbrachte toccata und fuge opfers als
orchesterstück muss ich ehrlich sagen
gar keine proteste fassung dieses
stückes bekannt als oli wert ist aber
man kann natürlich bestimmte
kompositionen auch über den computer
abspielen damit haut werden der siebente
box haben und so weiter so mit medi wie
auch immer sie können kompositionen auch
über den computer realisieren
akustische signale um
in meinen augen spricht nichts dagegen
dass als ein wirkliches musikstück
anzusehen und nicht nur als simulation
wie sehen sie also eine rein abgespielt
das musikstück beim sei es jetzt mit
medi sei es mit sound blaster mit
athleten mit ich weiß nicht was wird er
gebraucht
wenn du also doch niemand steht
also das können sie alles realisieren
mit dem computer mit der haut mit einer
guten soundkarte pc speaker auch ganz am
anfang einfache melodien commander keen
pippi und so weiter frage ist es eine
simulation und virtuelle realität wird
prozentual verteilt ist musik wie aber
sind alle elektronen die produzierten
und dann würde niemand auf die idee
kommen und zu sagen dass es keine echte
musik und sieben gut gut ab und genau
also die ganzen digitalen produktionen
werden ja auch eine simulation der
müssen uns fragen von wasser
simulationen
ich glaube daran sieht man dass man sich
nicht so sehr festhalten sollte an der
genese der musik die ebenso ist dass die
ursprünglich auf physikalischen objekten
produziert werden musste und glaube dass
das ein gutes beispiel ist genauso wie
wir musik hören physikalisch instrumente
binden
genauso sollen wir auch andere objekte
andere realitäten nicht nur genetisch
frühere
durch musikalische projekte bin muslim
existiere nicht
also wenn ich sage bloß deren rahmen
könnte schon wenig
der weg bis nach werden musik absehbar
sein der das so empfindet der musik an
sich ist doch kein grosser ja das eine
gute frage also sie weisen darauf hin
dass muss ich auf jeden fall irgendwie
der nachdemo die physikalisch in uns
geboren oder wie auch immer drehen muss
wenn man kann fragen uns musik
vielleicht direkt ist ein anderer zeuge
hörnerv angedockt werden könnten aber
auch diese dinge die dann kassieren sind
ja musikalisch jedenfalls fundiert man
muss dazu sagen dann kann man uns wieder
das problem der quali ja also diese
höreindruck dieses autistisches kanal
geht eben in seiner phänomenalen
qualität nicht auf durch die
physikalische beschreibung aber de facto
ist es so dass wir immer auch digital
produzierte musik auf irgendwelchen
physikalischen rechnern realisieren
müssen ja auch vom prinzip her wenn sie
sich die musik an schau darum das sind
alles jeden einzelnen ende also die
müssen halt dann irgendwie noch ihm aus
gegeben werden
ausgabe aber von der eingabe von hier
sind es alles nur einzeln oder was auch
immer elops systeme und das natürlich
was anderes als wenn wir jetzt schauen
wie ein orchester hat das ganze erzeugt
hat das nicht nur in und 1 sind das sind
letztendlich handlungen in einer zeit
die diese musik konstituieren man könnte
jetzt sagen gut auch der computer
verbringt vollzieht handlung
[Musik]
ja das eine gute frage dass man das ist
eine ganz komische frage worin besteht
die musik wird die musik eben realisiert
werden diese komposition oder bestimmte
musik in der abstrakten komposition bis
zur wahl gemacht und unternehmerischen
status der musik die mich auch
interessiert wird ich glaube dass die
musik immer diesen performative nast
denken sicher weil keine interpretation
ist dieselbe also das ist ja der reiz
der musik was wir haben dann notationen
aber warum sprechen wir von genialen
dirigenten oder genial solisten
eigentlich ist ja diese redeweise von
genialer musiker
wenn man streng sind streng genommen
sind falsch weil wenn man jetzt musik
recht reduziert sie wäre es ja nur eine
ausführung sprich eine reproduktion
etwas vorgegeben eine ausführung eine
durchführung etwas gegeben
der musiker könnte man die musikerin
könnte man denken imitieren oder ist da
nur das sprach wo das ausführende organ
dieses komponisten der komponist
drüberstehen aber der entspricht steht
hingegen dass jeder interpret das werk
aber so muss man sich das
dass es nicht so dass wir einfach
erzählen durchführen sondern gewisse
vorgaben wir haben vielleicht gewisse
akzente wir haben welche qualitäten wir
haben natürlich die noten die sind
gegeben
aber in welchem tempo wir so spielen wie
wir sie genau durchführen das ist der
freiheit des interpreten letztendlich
eingestellt und hier glaube ich kommt
dann wenn man wird seine kreativität
selbst auch eines musikers der eben
nicht erzeugen ich bin streng sich jetzt
der komposition ist jetzt ans tageslicht
also ich glaube tatsächlich meine teams
während musik existiert nur in der
durchführung dieser komposition beim
jahr sie beliebig ist er so spielt
wir sind also kleine musiker genau steht
das gehör
neben linie war der schweizer nicht und
genau das was für mich wichtig ich
glaube der beste musiker da stimme ich
ihnen zu genau also die musik ist jetzt
endlich das was zwischen den linien sich
abspielt oder zwischen den zeilen
sozusagen auch im gesamtschau in der
gesamtschau dieser komposition dem
ausdruck den man dem ergebnis nach als
in der form und eben nicht nur in den
materialien bestandteil
das war die rettung jetzt war hier noch
nicht mit mir
ach so werden merken dass man ja muss
ich auch ich denke ich und
formulierungen realisieren mussten weil
man kann die musik beispielsweise auch
vorstellen dass kreatives schreiben ohne
dass sie irgendwie sind oder spielt
trotzdem rauchen das ist immer noch eine
art wie sie ja interessant man könnte
sie jetzt natürlich fragen
die bieten wir in imaginären das eben
auch schon produziert man mal gute
komponisten und komponistinnen gute
musikerinnen und musiker die höheren das
was sie sehen gleich also die kann ich
jetzt nur teilweise begrenzten maße
jemand der ägypter ist der klingt
vielleicht sogar vierstimmig und er hört
dass sofort gehört dass im inneren uhr
vor dem inneren ohr was da steht und man
könnte es jetzt fragen ob dieses innere
erzeugen des lesens ich mich auch eine
reproduktion ist die dann eben nicht
nach außen treten
aber ich bin ich bin mir noch gar nicht
sicher ich weiß mein komponist
komponistin wirklich musiziert ob sie
wirklich performativ das musical ist es
beispiel beethoven
seit den letzten zehen zu haben haupt
kommt man ja dass sie nicht gehört und
er hat immerhin ab schließlich
ausgedrückt ich muss es gar nicht hören
ich sehe die struktur das ist die musik
ja man kann sie jetzt fragen ob es nicht
doch gehört hat die wienerin überhaupt
stand sie können sich der melodien
vorstellen wenn sie bäume haben dann
hören sie das ja im inneren ohr
sie können sich aber irgendwie eine
beliebige monologe innerliche vorstellt
und man könnte sie jetzt wagen diese
innere vorstellung die auch erzeugt
werden muss ob das nicht auch in den
gewisse form von realisierung von musik
ist das eine spannende frage
sie sehen hier auch in der musik im ohr
ist immer im bereich der virtualisierung
gar nicht mehr nach außen im stadtforst
also spannende frage kann ich nicht
entscheiden müsste man sich mal mit dem
eigens signal
den eigenen sinnen
beschäftigen oder sophie der musik
solche fragen werden dann zentral was
mich jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
nachholen möchte man möchte ist das
sozial und theologie der virtuellen
realität
er sagt jetzt hier physiker bodzek
scanner die unter 96 world von tears und
wirtschaft vor allem eins eine
physikalische objekte können nicht in
virtuellen umgebungen produzierten samt
physiker genommen
kenny vernommen absolventa peter
alexander flash appeal pizza
wahlcomputers do not have the power to
produce physiker otto hell für große
chaos zu prototype physiker vom awi ist
city phänomen anderer komponist of love
can do service computersystem kulturell
ganz auf die weisse sneakers hälfte
quasi applaus auf youtube white and
visual editor phänomens der abend unter
dem motto the search in wales physiker
endete ist ein images sound shapes in
kraft also gewicht los
also letztendlich auch phänomene die
nichtraucher zeitliche reibung
ausgesetzt
konsequent ihren jetzt konkretes
beispiel bei der version träume im
august place bekannt in dem eine
erklärung performance auf ca die meinung
das haben wir auch glaube ich jetzt so
gesehen haben und dann bringen wir uns
dieses kreises und da wird es noch
deutlicher sichtbar gut ja beim also das
wäre jetzt ein bisschen entgegengesetzt
wir haben jetzt die meinung vertreten
ein musikstück wissen und dann also muss
ich es mit musik wenn sie irgendwie
ausgeführt wird jetzt kann man sich das
fragen wie das mit einem kreis ist ein
kreis der muss ja nicht die sind erst
einmal sonne kreist ist einfach
bestimmte technologische das logische
verhältnis und des marktplatzes für
punkten abstimmen und erfasste das kann
man sich jetzt wirklich fragen die man
erkannt würde jedenfalls sagen dass ein
kreis immer nur ein kreis ist wenn er
durchgeführt wird das ist ganz
interessant
ganze 30 kilometer könnte man ja auch
geometrisch fassen könnte sicherlich den
preis nicht als was bloß zahl mäßiges
gefasst zur als geometrisches was in
einer fläche denkt die modelle
mathematik würde den kreis gar noch
geometrisch bestehen arithmetisch oder
ich weiß nicht wie aber kann tätiges
sagt der kreis existieren nur dann wenn
er letztendlich in einem raum mit einer
ebene letztendlich gezeichnet wird aber
eben mich jetzt in der wirklichen welt
so sind unsere der rhein eine chance
form des raumes wie ein dreieck nur dann
existiert wenn wir es in der weiten
landschaft vor des raumes konstruieren
das heißt kann nur das sagen ein kreises
nur ein kreis wenn er konstruiert ist
und das wird er wiederum passen damit zu
der musik wie wir sie verstand ein
lustiges und der musik wenn sie
konstruiert ist als damit will ich sagen
die noren und so wie wir sie sehen das
sind nur soll die anleihe ist die
anleitung und musik ist der daten musik
wenn wir diese anleitung durch natürlich
besteht der unterschied zum kreis darin
dass ein kreis immer ein kreis ist gibt
es keine spiele ich kann der kreis nicht
ein bisschen dreckige machen oder ein
bisschen oval oder ist es kein kreis
während bei der musik wenn wir die
anleitung haben können wir unendlich
viel draus macht das ist immer noch
letztendlich muss das ist dieses stück
es ist dieses stück egal brings internet
also ich hab ganz viel spieler muss er
durch diesen die richtigen noten spielen
aber was zwischen den noten stattfindet
das ist ja eines spannenden müssen da
habe ich ihm natürlich die spielraum
weswegen wir auch eben die ganz große
klassiker der musik auch nach hunderten
von jahren immer wieder neue aufführen
können und neue erkenntnisse neue
aspekte dieses werk sehen und ja ich war
ja gut es gibt ja dann den moderneren
drei atonale musik und es gibt das über
die serielle musik des stockhausen und
zwei oder noch so ein zufall moment mit
reinkommt ist auch ein gesetz natürlich
unter musik sondern sich zu musik
deswegen bei der haftung sind gibt es
keinen grund warum hier nicht so damit
nehmen sie eben auch von der wintergrüne
bis zur renaissance und atonalen sind
sind es geräusche
ja das sind angefragt und da gibt es
nämlich ihr mathematischen beweis dass
wird sie können klassische sind mit
ihrer mannschaft austauschen behandlung
wenn sie verstehen das ist ein großer
richtig ja messe das atonale machen dann
haben sie es werde nämlich gehörig aus
das erkennen musik spannende punkt ist
die riesen ich sehe schon ich muss das
seminar bietet musik sie haben recht ich
hoffe wir sprechen also es ist ja nicht
so dass nach in halle wo sich einfach
gegen ihn zufällig ist sondern atonale
musik fort auch bestimmte regeln
anschauen
die zwei stunden sieht die anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts entwickelt
wurde
da gibt es ganz schlecht geregelt
welchen guten wie vor dürfen und wieder
die man beispielsweise wiederholt werden
darf und genau so wird es auch bei der
für jeden muss ich bei der
stochastischen so dass ein vergleich auf
den ersten moment ein bisschen suchen
egal
und die klassischen kamin gesetzten 30
das ist schon klar aber trotzdem gibt es
immer noch regeln die gefördert werden
es gibt eine komposition zu sehen sie
müssen immer den nächsten der schleif
trägt darin anders gesagt was ist denn
musik an sich
das ist eine emotionale ich muss muss
ich auch schöner film
es gibt ja auch leute die musik fühlen
will und deswegen gibt es sowas
überhaupt deswegen hat man sowas
überhaupt mal formuliert ja also ein
spannendes thema ich sehe schon die zwei
in zwei semestern muss ich hier seminare
für das mit der musik die krise schon
[Musik]
also ihr jetzt bitte jedes beispiel top
juristen aus erkennbar und der lautet
die diagnose
6 es ist ein normales ist es für sie
behauptet man 100 ist century ex ist in
physischer form also vorhin sagte er
computer haben nicht die kausale kraft
und physikalische polit er zu stützen
ich kann nicht komplett per computer
kann ich nicht einen schlüssel
hersteller er seinen schlüssel aus
mithalten denken sie an raumschiff
enterprise da gibt es da diese geräte
dann glücklicher neues gerät produzieren
bekennt sie das next generation mit
picasso
da gibt es solche solche art und
mikrowellen das so sehen die aus und
typen die da was ein produzieren wir
hier so ein apfel und kontoführung
ausritt physikalische dann aber in
jedenfalls was es gibt es ein hologramm
aber die sind keine physikalischen
objekt aber jetzt sagt er hier eine
ausnahme gibt es bei kommt
dass sie physikalische objekte
reproduzieren können wenn diese
physikalischen projekte nicht essenziell
und physikalische form existieren und
hier denke jetzt an das geld reicht wenn
sie geldscheins anschauen dann gerne
geldschein ist physikalisch objekt aber
geld existiert neben nicht essenziell
physical genauso so ist es wichtig
genommen als er produziert nicht direkt
ein physikalisch abwehr produziert etwas
was gleichwertig ist mit einem
physikalischen aufgelegt was eigentlich
mit dieselbe so wirklich seine selber
und theologische technologischen status
hat wie ein oscar
also es kommt mit den physikalischen
objekt dann letztendlich insofern gleich
altes leben
sag ich mal so diese zeichen struktur
hatte aber ist ein guter hinweis ist
nicht notwendig so dass es was und was
physikalisch korrekt hervor und
die insel
das ist keine ausnahme zu mir
nun machen sie fest dass drei ereignisse
2 1 1
so sollten fotos
doch was muss dass wir hier nicht
ja also wir diesem fall es ist zb sohn
der wert nein oder die kausale kraft die
vom geld ausgeben ob ich jetzt fünf euro
in bitcoins habe oder fünf euro
das leben hier als geld schon fünf toren
da geht dann von dem geht dann von
diesen geldschein letztendlich diese
kausale kraft aus aber natürlich nicht
nur auf basis dieses papiers sind die
kausale kraft wird ermöglicht durch die
interaktive gemeinschaft das war die
institution des vertrauens sind die wir
hier schon mal es geht jetzt endlich um
den sozialen schutz
das ist das der grund und was der autor
jetzt hier sagen möchte es eben das
motto logisch können wir als können wir
den virtuellen leben keine physikalische
objekte erfolgt
wir wissen aber was wir können sagt er
sind physikalische phänomene wie zum
beispiel tonsignal wie zb bilder ja ich
kann hier wenn siegfried rau habe ich
einen besseren eindruck
der ist physikalisch realisiert und ich
kann jetzt endlich ein foto davon machen
digitales foto des 001 zerlegen und es
ist ähnlich jetzt endlich das geht seit
der physikalische phänomene also
phänomene kann nicht digital realisierte
das ja ich würde auch nicht sagen dass
die simulation ist als ich würde nicht
sagen dass wenn ich jetzt diesen blick
aus dem fenster
[Musik]
digital kamera aufnehmen das dass das
simulation ist meinen könnte es laut
zwei mit kopie oder aber noch klar wird
es mit mit tönen
ich kann mit computern mittlerweile
musik so wer ist so so gut erzeugen dass
es kein unterschied mehr macht zum
orchester gut dann wäre es natürlich
wiederum auf eine gewisse weise und
sagen wer ist eine simulation wenn ihr
jetzt orchestermusik digital produzieren
es gibt es ja ich kann er über digitale
ist es jetzt hier eine simulation oder
ist es letztendlich nur eine virtuelle
realität dieses orchesters geht zum
fenster aufmachen
nur darum geht es ja
können wir also hat die touren in eine
vision zu hören sofort originalgetreu
das orchester das ist eigentlich
erreicht und im konzertsaal reicht ja
also ich hatte eben so ein bisschen
zweifel weil wenn man jetzt liegt
digital produzierte gegenstimmen berlin
stimme berlin und klang erzeugen dann da
bin ich mir nicht sicher man könnte
schon sagen dass seine simulation wie
erzeugen künstlich sie sind lang aber
schauen sie damit auf neben der quali es
ist dieselbe qualen der geigenklang also
phänomenologischen interessiert sie es
nicht wie dieser klang erzeugt wurde aus
der technologischen schritt in die
mobile technik gerade ein bisschen dazu
nehmen wir das interview linie höher
das ist ja schon von der gemäße schon
der überzeugung schon toll wenn es bei
ihnen ankommt wenn man dann das kleine
erst wenn sie es gewusst haben und ich
denke dass wir manchmal denken
also diese phänomene könnten hat es
quasi darstellen dass es für die quali
nicht entscheidend ist existenz weise
theologisches hat dass der quasi wie sie
erzeugt wurden
solange es wirklich als qual als
geigenklang war deswegen würde ich sagen
würde ich sagen das orchester musik die
digital erzeugt wurde
virtuell und die als solche wahrgenommen
dass die nicht simulierte orchester muss
wissen virtual realisierte und
körperlich sogar manche würden sagen des
bundes orchester simulation würde ich
aber wegen des qualms nicht so spannende
versehen simulation und virtuelle
realität spannendes thema groß die
abgrenzung genau jetzt sagt er hier bei
beckmann access americom menschen und
conventions changing ortmann existenz
digitales marketing content sales und
sales awards und die fahrzeuge als
präsidentin und da kann man hier ist die
kamera durch die überhaupt schafft man
es dass man essentials ist in physischer
form existiert
manni ist ein essenzieller frauen lebten
junkie physik ja die würde ich zustimmen
also gelb ist nicht nur ein notwendiger
essentielle preise physikalisch greifbar
sondern nur kompetenter weise ich kann
eben geld keine werte realisieren auf
andere weise gut jetzt kann man sich
fragen muss nicht geld am ende doch
immer
die wieder material instanziert sein
realisieren zeit wenn sie siemens jetzt
digitales konto haben fragte ich sie
wohl ist jetzt viel geld
wo befindet sich ihr geld das ihr konto
und befinden sich mit frei machen ganz
kurseinheiten das es gar nicht gibt also
ich hätte es nicht erst zum mittelwert
sondern das ist wie früher wenn man
jetzt an die genese des geldes der
anfang sind das ja auch schon schreiben
an der auch barenboims jetzt sein geld
tatsächlich in wirklichkeit nur einem
sagen wir werden ihr konto beträgt genau
richtig als und das ist eben der prüfung
von botschafter versprach bullock ist
weil das digitale als virtuelle
virtualität kurz gesagt muss ich nicht
nur digital bemerkbar und virtualität
gibt es eben schon seit
sozialunternehmen existieren die werte
generiert hatte früher muschel als geld
gebunden oder selbst gold wird der
bedingt durch die seltenheit und zu
lassen da sieht man schon hier also bei
goldes ist oder ist der wert greifbaren
und zwar deswegen bei gold eben sehr
selten aber schuldscheine zb oder eben
auch konnten die jetzt
digital war sehr genau dasselbe dann
beim konto macht es kann unterschrieben
haben da haben sie mir gesagt irgendwie
nochmal bewegen aber dass ein buch hängt
auch nicht dran existieren also da ist
das geld jetzt auch nicht drin
so ist es halt die realität von
subjekten die eben verbindlichkeiten
eingehen
also ich glaube dass virtuelle realität
kurz gesagt auch was mit relation ali t
zu tun also mit einer mit verhältnissen
und zwar nicht irgendwelche verhältnisse
sondern der virtualität scheint mir
realität durch inter subjektive
verhältnis bestimmt zu sein
und jetzt kommen noch mal hier auf dem
johnson johnson von 19500
sicherheitsgewerbe unter margaret kanal
saint quentin of the witch project
access und dem exzentrischen physiker in
richmond army content also es gibt immer
geld ist zb conti genter weise materiell
oder physikalische also geld muss nicht
notwendigerweise physikalische
existieren geld es gibt geld auch nicht
auf geld bei have used as serie james
kemp
der fonds mit dem wort mikrowelle der
fundamente des station kann mit wenig
resonanz ist schon realität für die
karriere die konsistente sagte jamie
oliver objective index ist independent
auf einen technischen realität
konzerthaus in diesem fall emmely
objektiv aber die aufgabe schlosses auf
social interpretation waren konstant
soziale realitäten sind ergebnis von
sozialer konstruktion produktion scheint
jetzt ein bisschen zu schwach zu sein
kommt die verbindlichkeiten bis jetzt
kurz also es geht hier um
verbindlichkeit und ich glaube das wort
verbindlichkeit enthält das wort
verbinden
das heißt verbindlichkeit kommt nur
durch bezüge zu stande
und zwar von recht stabilen bezogen oder
redaktionen dieses glaubens
rechtsverbindlichkeit bedeutet
verbindlichkeit nicht kann ich
ich eine person gemacht werden weil die
personen sich nicht verbinden kann
interessant und einer aufspannung kann
innerhalb dessen geltung capture dh nach
meiner theorie brauchen wir mindestens
zwei personen um verbindlichkeit
hergestellt weil die sich miteinander
verbinden und sich gar nicht mit werden
durch wie auch immer vertrage verträgen
so dass etwas an wert hat ich kann
alleine nicht ein wert bestimmen
wäre nämlich eine quantifizierung
wendigkeit ja genau
genauso könnte man so genannten genau
eine form von verbindlichkeit eine
besonders intensive form von
verbindlichkeit und man kann das
durchaus graduell sehen
ich glaube auch dass wir geld die sie
sagen geltende werte als einem
quantitativ und mit einer qualität und
eine quantitative form von
verbindlichkeiten und schreiben können
weil wir nur durch diese quantität auch
so was wie kurswechsel haben oder auch
kursschwankungen haben
ich glaube dass der wert eines projekts
zum beispiel am markt dass wir damit
zusammenhängt dass die quantität der
grad der verbindlichkeit sich ändert
also die basis die garantie dieses
wertes und das interesse dass das sinkt
und je lockerer die verbindlichkeit wird
bezüglich auf diesen wert desto geringer
wird sein wert dieses objekt desto
geringer wird sagte würde ich sagen
geben stärker das netz der
verbindlichkeit ist in dem dieser wert
auf eben dieser raum des wertes auf
gesprochen wird desto wertvoller ist als
ich würde mehr definiert als quantität
der verbindlichkeit
das scheint ihr recht plausibel zu sein
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
aber der kleine exkurs wir müssen
nämlich gleich zum nächsten thema gehen
aber darauf führt das hin
wie sieht es mit der würde eines
menschen der würde die absoluten würde
eines menschen und da würde ich sagen
dass es nicht mehr nur die quantitative
verbindlichkeit sind weil kein mensch
jetzt hier der mensch hat jetzt schon
während 95 prozent und die person hat
eben den würde von 80 prozent
sondern da ist eben eine qualitative
keine quantitative bin ich kein die
würde eines menschen ist nicht eine
marktwert an kurswert ausgesetzt heute
ist die würde meine würde ist heute um
zehn prozent gesunken
es würden sie mir sagen würden immer
sagen meine würde ist konstant auf 100
prozent oder eben nicht entweder oder
aber eigentlich würden wir alles sagen
sie es auf hundert prozent immer sie ist
ist kein kursschwankungen ausgesetzt und
damit wird er sagen dass unser wert der
vergänglichkeit von personen wichtiges
quantitatives nichts tat um ihr wahres
sein dass qualitativ lassen
und hier kann man sie jetzt wagen die
wird durch welche form von
verbindlichkeit wird personale würde und
zwar spannendes riesen spannendes thema
von christa johnson also wirklich ganz
ganz
denke und er sagt es hier nochmal für
flüssigere objects effektiv nutzen lässt
red derstandard.at apples groepper
tresen wird hier werden des electric
light in ihr haus in west ham service
wenig gelingt mit dem concept cx
pressing physikeffekte konstant
jetzt hören heißt der refrain aber das
ist zum beispiel ganz klar gerade behält
exis independet auf die
präsentationssoftware jungen dieses
existiert wenn man bis nach reisen ihres
topmodells encounters of cancer causes
and sales zum spielkonzepte kontrakte
glas auf ex und blutfettwerte aufgehört
of money mit harvard university of essex
endete care projekt my kitchen gratis
ja also sagt jetzt also selbst der
offizier ist ein so ein soziales fakten
bin ich mir nicht
sich also habe ich das ein bisschen
natürlich dass das einkommen ist wird
erst dadurch möglich dass der
kommuniziert sich in einem interview
blickt iwe kontext verbindet das
gebraucht
martin heidegger würde es sagen der zu
handeln heißt als das ist ein dass ein
gegenstand das als mittel zum zweck
gebraucht wird und die zwecke innerhalb
des ist seine bedeutung bekommt dies
sind abhängig von einer sozialen
realität wenn es keine freien subjekte
gebe wurde keine lebewesen
dann würde anschauten ein korkenzieher
keine funktion haben
man könnte etwas sagen er hätte nur
praktisch praktisch keine funktion
traktor aber die möglichkeit nachher die
schulleiter funktion nämlich wenn es
weiße flecken gebe deswegen finde ich
dieses läuft ein bisschen schwierig ich
würde sowas sagen geben zum beispiel
universitätsdiplom und qualitäts
abschluss her
das ist mit sozialer realität weil wo
ist dieser abschluss ja auf diese gurken
schön aber wenn sie die urkunde
verlieren dann für
ihren status sind gehen sie zum
prüfungsamt und lassen sie neu
ausstellen
wiemers des prüfungsamtes schaut im
computer nach ob sie das hatten aber im
computer ist es natürlich auch nicht das
führt uns wieder zur selben sache wie
bankkonten oder schuld schafft und da
wir bei dem universitätsplatz filme auf
die universitäts verfassung universitäts
ordnung auf die prüfungsanordnung
dekorieren da wo es die prüfung
gebrauchen
ganz spannend wie lange existiert
prüfungsordnung schauen sie uns gibt's
die neue prüfungsordnung die leiche dann
abgeschafft
ganz spannende frage als ich wollte nur
sagen wenn über den begriff der
virtualität können wir uns sehr gut der
digitalität mehr obwohl digitale
realität nicht die einzige virtuelle
realität ist sondern eben auch geld
virtuelle realität ist und dass du
können jetzt sagen überspringen hat
darauf vor diesen hinweisen und jetzt in
dem
zweiten hälfte dieser sie zu kommen wir
auf das thema ethik der digitalität zu
sprechen
das ist ein ganz spannendes thema wie
schon am anfang sagte und es hängt
natürlich auch zusammen mit der
ontologie und der bedeutung
bei fragen und zwar in wiefern durch die
digitalisierung ethischen probleme
achten sie immer dabei wenn wir das
diskutieren achten sie auf der
unterschied zwischen technik und kultur
digitalisierung und der vitalität sind
diese probleme die mit der
digitalisierung einhält andere hat also
diese ethischen probleme sind diesen
part als analogie ethische probleme das
ist ein anstieg an logistisches problem
ja zum beispiel hat ein logistisches
problem ist ob ich der ob lehrerinnen
und lehrern schüler in der schule
süchtige griff sondern es ja vielleicht
hat das ist ein analoge fragt ob sie die
züchtigung ob man kinder schlagen
ob man tiere mit tieren tierversuche
machen darf das sind das sind analoge
juristische probleme ich glaube jetzt
eingeführt alles was ich fühle mich hier
präsentiert ist wirklich nur vorwurf
dass es alles noch stark einer debatte
ausgesetzt ich würde sagen jetzt
überlegen sie machen wir haben jetzt
drei begriffe und der nook digital und
auch noch virtuellen und das spannende
ist
ich glaube dass der begriff des
virtuellen über beckhams erfindung
nehmen die sie eben auch einen druck
durchaus darstellen aber anderes thema
also analog würde ich sagen sind die mir
einfach der traditionellen tätig die
würde ich jetzt einfach mal
die frage nach gewalt zu erweitern
jetzt könnte man sich vor ein gibt es
virtuelle ethische probleme ich glaube
auch zb glaube ich dass es virtuell
ethische probleme dann gibt wenn wir es
mit geld zu tun haben ja mit geld mein
geld was virtuelles geld ist zu sagen
etwas was zwischen der digitalen also
was also zwei seiten haben unser geld
hat einerseits findet sie etwas
physikalisches und träge aber es muss es
nicht haben wie wir gesehen haben und
vom bankkonto oder von schuld all das
sind formen der probleme zum beispiel
betrug finanzbetrug haben das würde ich
sagen ist ein ethisches problem weil es
nicht mehr nur sage ich jetzt mal
physikalisch sie auf physikalischen
ebene abspielt sondern der antrag
dimension bekommen und jetzt kann sich
vor allem was ich da digitale
italienische das sind probleme die sich
eben aus der digitalisierung ergeben und
die wie mir scheint auch stark mit der
virtualität ist wie viel ist diese welt
der digitalität ich spreche sich für die
digitalisierung bietet unter dem titel
wie ist diese von normalität kann also
von ethik jetzt mal annehmen würde also
mit gewalt schauen sie gewalt kann sich
gewalt virtuelle spannende frage also
delikte bestimmte form von tüten
gewaltdelikte sind gewaltdelikte
notwendigerweise analogen lassen sich
gewaltdelikte virtuelle realisieren oder
digital werden kann ich ihnen wird
schwerer gewalt zu fühlen
wie könnt ihr das machen wird sofern ich
zu viele tipps den zuschauern gegeben
ja aber ist das für sie ist es ist eine
form von gewalt sie haben recht es ist
psychoterror als er es ist spannend
ich habe ein anderes seminar mache ich
ins oben rechts und links form des
ungarischen werden könne ich glaube es
gibt formen des moralischen die digital
sind oder vielleicht sogar der
digitalität leider habe ich in der
nächsten sitzung mir das thema böse
ideologien unmoralische theologen
fordern
ich hätte sogar noch eine sitzung nur
der frage gewidmet ob sich digital
visual auch gewalt oder programms an
pässen das lässt aber jetzt überlegen
sie mal der normale begriff von gewalt
der traditionelle bietet von die wahl
bisher der physikalischen
es gibt sicherlich auch stalking und es
gibt mobbing und mobbing ist zb haben
sitzung nach den oben rechts in der
linken
mobbing ist eine form da nicht der
gewaltlosigkeit im physikalischen sinne
wenn ich jemanden model dann mache ich
psychoterror und zwar die meisten sind
eine gruppe das ist häufig viele gegen
einen lässt sich aber auch mobbing wo
eins zu eins relation herrschen und wo
eine personengruppe gibt gibt es auch
aber in der regel sagt der begriff des
mobbings ist eine gruppe ist daher der
begriff kommt von konrad lorenz aus der
verhaltensbiologie als morgens
eigentlich das verhalten von tieren in
der gruppe gegen andere einzelne
individuum einen anderen art die die
dann letztendlich mit gewalt fand sich
fernhalten und mobbing wäre eine form
von gewalt die aber nicht dem
klassischen oder dem physikalischen und
dem körperlichen gewalt den entspricht
was heißt drohen und astronomie
geständigen keinen treffen unter dem
mechanismus ja ok er lag damit um
unterscheiden ewald drohnen
ich würde es wirklich von dem von dmax
und dem akt oder von der handlung von
ereignis fest machen und dann also
drohnen schießen dann irgendwann eine
rakete und das ist eine physikalische
gewann der explodiert was mich
interessiert die frage gibt es virtuelle
also gibt es virtuellen verbrechen weil
damit mannes geben zum beispiel
beleidigung die jetzt in online und
online spielen und so betätigen oder zum
beispiel in chats oder soja und ich
glaube es liegt glauben persönlich
psychoterror ist natürlich möglich
die digital oder wird aber gemacht und
im physikalischen sinne gerichten als
auch das wäre der digitalität die
drohnen wäre schon wie das beispiel
physikalischen effekt wenn der rakete
einschnitten die rakete kann natürlich
digitale oder durch können sie nicht
abgefordert worden sein
ich meine jetzt aber die eigenes leben
damit an eine rakete explodiert und das
ist physikalisch geleitet werden ich
glaube dass der digitalität dass wenn
die vitalität eben
natürlich kann auch aus der digitalität
sich physikalische gewalt ergeben habe
ich glaube dass wir es hier mit
ethischen problemen zu tun haben die
nicht mehr direkt physikalisch gebunden
sondern ich glaube zum beispiel ich
bringe jetzt erreichten die probleme mit
dem wir es da zu tun haben sind nicht
mehr so zettel gibt es gewalt antun in
physikalischen sinne dass ich jetzt
irgendwie beraubt werde und festgehalten
werde und man mir das geld aus dem
rastlosen touch ziel und wir noch eine
rüber und das ist glaube ich nicht die
ebene der digitalen lebens betrifft sind
die glaube das betrifft so was wie
privat privatheit die datenschutz
wie recht auf anonymität usw
mir geht es aber gleich betroffen er ein
aber ich sehe den punkt schon den sie
gemacht werden
sie ziehen also machen
ich hätte bestimmt gut gemacht bei st
digital ist
genau wie durch und menschen nicht
wissen wir nicht
genau das ist ein punkt der markt dann
zur folge haben dass physikalische
gewalt im krieg entstehen
aber das ist dann letztendlich nur
ausläuft das zentrum der frage ist dann
eben nach der verantwortung
und das ist glaube ich wieder ein punkt
der digitalität digitalisierung im
begriff gewalt oder
ereignis zu beschreiben entwicklung
eines gemeinden können wir glaube ich
einerseits aus der perspektive des
betroffenen aus und dann würde ich sagen
aus der perspektive des kunden gebracht
der rest ohne abschluss ist der konzern
vor allem wie er es in ausgewählten
[Musik]
ja also ich stimme da hinzu dass wir
wenn wir verbietet sprechen oder auch
von gebäuden von unmoralischen immer
einen täter oder eine täterin haben ein
akteur und ein opfer und im infopunkt
empfinden bereich der kunst intelligenz
wird die frage nach dem akteur gemacht
haben wer ist jetzt der akteur von einer
solchen drohung oder bei neuronalen
netzwerk inwiefern ist das netzwerk ein
akteur zum beispiel der medizin wenn es
um diagnostische verfahren
das ist sicherlich eigentlich aber das
betrifft nicht nur die gewalt phänomens
betrifft die ursache das betrifft nicht
das phänomen der gewalt
ich glaube das phänomen der gewalt trägt
digital nicht auf also physikalisch
jedenfalls nicht werden
psychoterror vielleicht aber hier geht
es eher um die frage
vorsicht also um die frage hat der zu
recht die frage der schuld
verantwortlichkeiten eben nicht mehr so
sehr um jetzt gewalt als phänomen machen
wir sind aber wir kommen bei hard rock
darf sie noch mal darauf hinweisen auf
dieses buch von philip specht die 50
wichtigsten themen der digitalisierung
hilfreich auch wenn es jetzt keine
philosophischen anspruch hat aber dann
bringt doch hier einige großen guten
wahren überblick über die wichtigsten
themen und nicht philosophisch wie
gesagt er sei jetzt in unsere zukunft
zum wohle der gesellschaft zu gestalten
müssen wir zum einen die vielen
kritischen fragen diskutieren die sich
durch die digitale innovation auf zum
anderen müssen wir handlungsoptionen
werfen wie wir dir den herausforderung
der zukunft am besten gerecht
die erste teil ist in der philosophie
die sich mit der bewertung
menschenhandels gefasst im zentrum der
ethik ständig auseinandersetzung der
frage was gut ist und was schlechtes
handeln ist so hilft die ewig die würde
des einzelnen seines selbstbestimmung
und handlungsplan zu schützen zeiten in
den algorithmen unser leben zu nehmende
einflüssen ist ein ethischer kompass
wichtigeren liegt am computer kennen
keine werte keine noch eine kamera
natürlich kann man kann
dann regeln beibringen vielleicht kann
künstliche intelligenzen ganze gäste
moralisches verantwortungsbewusstsein
ist simulieren interessant im leben
führen zu wollen
ich habe damit zu meiner probleme weil
210 ist nicht realität als die
künstliche intelligenz
verantwortungsbewusstsein simuliert
man hat die per definition kein
verantwortungsbewusster als situation
ist von realität zu unterscheiden
das wäre dann auch keine virtuelle
realität werden virtuelle simulation in
der simulation
das finde ich jetzt nicht ganz klar ist
doch zunächst einmal liegt es an uns den
ethischen rahmen für technische
innovationen festzulegen wir müssen
grenzen definiert zwischen dem technisch
machbaren ethisch vertretbar
dabei müssen wir uns bewusst sein dass
wir naturgemäß ausgrenzt und jetzt denke
was dann heraus argumentieren geschichte
dollar genutzt und gezeigt dass manche
denken müsste mit der zeit überholt sind
und die anpassung von werten ein
normaler prozess ist und denken sie
zurück an den hof von harry darüber
leben im digitalen humanismus
das setzte der versuch einer begraben zu
entwickeln indem diese ganzen
technischen neuerungen ethisch
vertretbar durchgeführt wird
ich glaube dabei dass diese dass dieses
buch dass diese these buch so sehr alle
orientiert ist also ich glaube dass es
gut dass will es auch gar nicht sein
keine ethik der digitalität
das ist hier eine ethik der zweiten
natur der traditionellen kultur die
jetzt eben mit dem neuen phänomen der
digitalisierung zu rechnen
aber ich glaube was wir brauchen ist
eine der digitalität und nicht eine
ethik über die digitalen phänomene die
auf der analogen ethik besser also
irgendwo im prinzip mit wahrheit und
gibt es eine gibt es etliche fair news
also wenn ich sie recht verstehen
sagen sie jetzt ja natürlich
also genau also die mobile schmiede zum
beispiel jürgen also wellen oder die
ethik setzt voraus dass leben
die wahrheit befolgt wird im sinne des
versprechens von alles halten zur
versprechungen das vermeiden von lüge
betrug und so weiter und diese kommen
dann der lüge die lassen sich natürlich
ganz
in der sphäre der digitalisierung der
vitalität realisieren
fake news zum beispiel als solche gab es
immer aber denken sie zurück denken sie
an die twitter möglichkeit wer hat das
letzte mal über twitter geredet ich mag
oben rechts und den kreis an die stelle
springt twitter schaffte es durch die
geringe zeichen zahlen die an zur
verfügung steht
wieviel 240 zeigen oder so irgendjemand
musste ist 82 gelb schafft es einen raum
zu bringen innerhalb dessen natürlich
thesen sehr pointiert formuliert werden
also twitter bietet nicht raum für
argumentationen für lange begründung
zusammenhänge youtube in den dschungel
und diese form von twitter die
erleichtert ist eben auch fade -
auszubauen und zwar deswegen weil
twitter die möglichkeit bietet postings
ganz schnell zieht eine teilung haben
wir uns gesagt jetzt mal ist das
wichtigste bei twitter nicht likes zum
tradewinds gehofft ist sagen sag ich mal
weiter geht es am ende für
nachgeplappert wird mit schweden könnte
man mit
er besitzt deutschen ich glaube wir
müssen es auf den punkt kommen und
deswegen übersetzt überspringe ich das
jetzt möchte man wirklich jetzt zu
entscheidungen kommen das können sie
alles nachlesen wer hier vielleicht noch
dass ich habe vor dem rein gemacht das
internet of things wandelt sich zum
internet auf everything und macht uns
immer mehr zu verletzten gläsernen
menschen autos speichern und sendung
automatisch daten um zu schaffen hat ein
wildes und anderes motorrad anwendungen
informieren unseren arzt ob wir uns
ausreichend bewegt auto und
krankenversicherungen locken uns mit
rabatten wenn wir unsere daten teilen
ist dieser trend in unserem ist dieser
trend in unserem sinne gelaufen ihre
mögliche gefahr dass menschen die
möglichst wenig persönliche daten teilen
möchten
in unserer gesellschaft benachteiligt
werden das würde ganz ganz zentrale
fragen und hier greifen von mir wieder
zwei begriffe nämlich inter objektivität
die menschen werden zu gegenständen
gemacht zum quantitativen messbaren
hätten aber auch externen
externalisierung von gedanken weil wir
eben in der digitalen sphäre unsere
innerlichkeit nach außen spielten und
im internet sind internet das finde ich
eine ganz spannende frage
diese frage stellt sich glaube ist so
salz diese digitalität zu wenige ich
glaube dass das eine wirkliche neue
problematik ist generelle frage auch
noch konzerts nicht vergessen hatte hier
rein zu nehmen
die leitfrage bekommen wir das hier in
der händler der digitalisierung die
realität mit dem neuartigen ethischen
problemen oder sind das nur alte von
alte moralischen problematik in neuem
gewand und digitale gewandt frage 3 hat
sie also entweder oder glauben sehen die
digitalisierung bringt genuin neuartige
ethische probleme mit sich wer würde das
bedeuten dass sagen er würde sagen wir
nicht sind das in die traditionellen die
sich eben jetzt okay und ich muss sagen
nicht nein dazu seien die aufwendungen
also ich schließe mich dieser meinung
universum er an aber da hat es jemanden
stört vielleicht sagen dass wir alle so
problemlos laufen also ist es die morgen
ihren massenphänomen wo viele meistens
gegen ein treffen und das gleiche haben
wir eigentlich im internet nur dr
wir haben durch diese vernetzung sehen
wir das halt ins morgendliche viel
stärker auftritt unter dem motto lieder
übers herz ihn schwierig genau das ist
eigentlich so was
ein verstärktes mobbing ist aber durch
die vielen kursen teilnehmen sagt
exponentiell stärker ist und sie würden
sagen jetzt in diesem fall größere
anzahl macht noch kein neues phänomen
man könnte jetzt natürlich argumentieren
sagen durch die struktur des internets
die eben eine struktur ist die
vielleicht nicht analog ist zu unserer
interaktiven strukturen analogen wird
durch diese neue struktur wenn es wieder
heißt es treten auch dann neue phänomene
man könnte ihnen jetzt sicherlich recht
geben und sagen sogar dass mobbing kein
problem weshalb eine digitale form von
nudeln aber könnte sagen vielleicht gibt
es eben ganz neue phänomene jetzt einen
datenschutz- also dem zwang zur
selbstoptimierung zur selbst öffnung zum
anbinden an ein informationsnetz bezogen
vergehen zusammen mit der raumzeit
möglichkeit wenn der wissen zu tun haben
die eben auf analoge ebene wo wir uns
entziehen können wie privat nicht mehr
und würde bezogen das mobbing wird zu
recht gehabt ich zeigen dass es im
digitalen morgens sich um nichts neues
handelt aber es wird offen lassen ob es
nicht doch noch antreffen menge gibt die
wirklich neu sind weil es sehr viele
verschiedene wenige politische
problematiken genutzt
ja und auch die kombi davon kommen in
deutschland auch die kommen und jetzt
gibt es einen internet charakter der
seine versetzung mit aus 13 digitalen
grundrechte die hat unser der heiko maas
hat das mal eine zeit in richtung der
zeit hatte die mal vorgestellt
also besitzt dieses grundrecht die
werden sie merken wir sind jetzt beginnt
ein bisschen die politische philosophie
auch recht und ethik ist entspannt
systeme also 13 digitale grundrecht und
jetzt können sich auch fragen ergeben
sich diese grundrechte aus dem analogen
grundrechten die wir haben oder
entstehende neue gewicht jeder mensch
hat das recht auf zugang zu finden
ich möchte selber fahren hatte daher
nicht ja ich stelle sie noch vor also
jeder mensch hat das recht über seine
digitale identität selbst zu bestimmen
jeder mensch hat ein recht auf vergessen
werden kein mensch darf zum objekt eines
algorithmus werden
der mensch ist mehr als ein daten profil
jeder mensch hat ein recht darauf dass
seine arbeit angemessen bezahlt wird
wenn er dienstleistungen im internet
verbringt oder silber das insein
vermittelt alle urheber und ausübenden
künstler haben das recht auf einen
fairen anteil an
erträgen der digitalen nutzung ihrer
werke jeder mensch hat ein recht auf
datensicherheit
jeder mensch hat das recht auf eine
analog gewählt die finde ich am besten
wir sagen niemand darf ungerechtfertigt
benachteiligt werden weil der digitalen
dienstleistungen nicht gewusst haben
dass wenn ich dann sprang ein recht auf
eine analogie werden das finde ich
wirklich sehr denken jährige
was halten sie davon also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich sehe natürlich junger
mensch braucht gewachsen ist direkt mit
digitalen geräten können sollte sich den
punkten nicht tätigkeit
es wird ja auch niemand mehr sagen sie
haben ein recht auch überhaupt nicht
benachteiligt werden beispielsweise den
gleichen konsums programm haben die
fernsehleute ahnung haben hier das
gleiche
das eigentlich nur ein neues
informations ein bisschen vorstellen
dass fast 40 jahren vorausgesetzt geld
ist man eben den internetzugang genutzt
um an informationen zu kommen genau ist
glaube ich auch was ich glaube also ich
sehe ich das nicht glaube dass nur eine
frage der zeit also dann werden wir zum
beispiel heute sagt da habe ich benutze
keine elektrischen geräten wir benutzen
keine den tischen rede dessen ich möchte
ich möchte heizen mit holz und kohle als
mir scheint es alle noten zu sein dass
ich als das verhältnis von
digitalisierung im internet zum elektro
zu elektrischen induktion zu sein
scheint mir das selber zu sagen
elektrische der dimension von kronen
naja es gibt ja nur zwei spiele habe ich
ja die amischen jahren die aktivisten
die amischen richtig wobei die arme hoch
gewinnen gehören ja nicht alle
romantiker bestimmt und die amischen
haben aberglaube hat bin ich
mittlerweile auch schon ihre smartphones
also die arme schon englisch gibt es ja
einiges in der ganz komplexe
verhältnisse manche haben dann auch die
haben halt dann gut aus sondern alles
gut aus 19 jahrhundert aber haben halt
auch erstmal und die mannschaft freue
mich auch dass das nicht meine hand ist
ihm ja also ein bisschen also die gestik
ist ich gebe mich jetzt halt so
beherrschend aber zb wenn ja mehr
riesenfan gezogen brauchen die ihre
traktoren also die die machen das
baulich mehr von hand des verstandes das
ist die in den usa ist die felder so
riesig groß und die ganze
datenverarbeitung ich glaube auch dass
die computer haben den fan zonen
produktion geht haben die auch ihre ihre
hilfsmittel aber sie haben natürlich
gewisse trends l form bewahrt
aber ich glaube als zum beispiel können
wir uns jetzt fragen folgt irgendwann
auch die pflicht diesen
paradigmenwechsel sitzung können wir
jemanden zwingen das mit ich habe einen
diskussion kürze mit dem
person und die meinte sie habe keine e
mail adresse das zeige dass sich dass
ich eine e mail adresse zu werden er hat
den richtigen eindruck einig gibt es
also eigentlich wird diese diese meinung
nicht mehr lange möglich sein also ich
glaube es wird irgendwann vielleicht
dazu kommen wo es wie man ja keiner mehr
hat und der summe wussten nachteilen
ausgesetzt sein wird dass er fast nicht
mehr partizipieren werden sich dann
indirekt machen das machen andere
anmelden genau genommen zusammengenommen
sind nicht die spannende frage die
spannende ich halten entscheidende frage
für die ganze tisch ist
[Musik]
gibt es ein recht eine regierung zu
haben zu beanspruchen wo wir nicht mit
gitarre müssen und man kann sagen wenn
ich zu hause bin in meinen vier wänden
da kann ich alle geräte aus stecken und
dann kann man macht ein ganzer
zugegangen als die frage ist halt dient
können wir ein recht einklagen zweifel
dass wir auf analoge weist bestimmte
dinge tun wie zum beispiel einschreibung
sondern auch die immatrikulation mit
unterschriften haben wir das recht und
ich glaube wir haben es nicht also ich
glaube es wir haben keine rechtliche
moralischen anspruch auf analoge formen
der interaktion
ich glaube wir haben es nicht und zwar
genauso wenig wie wir es nun haben zu
sagen ich möchte jetzt nicht meine pizza
mit der mikrowelle oder mit elektroherd
machen sind ich möchte sie jetzt mit
holz heizen mit holz offen
jetzt hier ein neues kurz vor oder mit
dampf betrieben möchte ich jetzt nach
berlin waren mit der dann vor ich glaube
es ist ziemlich nehm ich glaube einfach
dann gibt es eine gewisse impfpflicht
erscheint mit diesen neuen technischen
entwicklungen mitzugehen
sofern sie uns ein alter gereicht um das
gefängnis auch in einem interview
blieben gemeinschaft anerkannt wird dass
das einfach einen wechsel einigen
ländern nächste stufe ist ein nächste
revolution sowie eben dampfgetriebenen
turbinen technik von elektrizität
technik revolutionär den normalen glaube
ich auch dass glaube das bedarf einer
pflicht sind beim diesen prozess mit
wenn es eine erleichterung bedeutet und
ich brauche dass die täter die silberne
richtung bedeutet weil die reibung wenn
es physikalisch gesprochen raumzeit
nicht aufgehoben wird und dass diese
reibungslose keinen digitalen denken sie
mal weiteres beispiel briefverkehr
kommunikation das ist glaube ich das
entscheiden
niemand schreibt fast nur mehr seine
die beiden am start ich glaube es gibt
noch ein passus in der promotionsordnung
dass man dort arbeiten auch noch
handschriftlich abgeben kann ich glaube
es geben habe ich glaube es eine frage
der zeit bis so etwas nicht mehr
angenommen würde
das wäre dann keine gültige doktor und
genauso e-mail verkehren
der schreibende briefe man kann sich
jetzt natürlich daran halten ist damit
verloren gehen wenn man keine briefe mit
schreibt gibt es eine große debatte ist
ethische debatte wie das warum diese e
mails führen dazu dass man sich keine
richtigen gedanken gemacht
der stil für schlechte sicht das sind
immer noch floskeln ja da die
kommunikation mit oberflächlichen genau
wie ich weiter und mit dazu ansprechen
das wäre glatt wie ein blendendes
voraussetzen dass alle
nutzen können dann müssen wir werden
hier auch die erste punkt sagt
eigentlich dass alle diese möglichkeiten
haben zum beispiel das ist ja eigentlich
ganz lustiges lied jetzt mal eine
ausbildung
dann vernichtet werden weil die werden
wir dann gesehen wird als die
möglichkeit um einen politischen
gegenteiligen und genau so ist es
eigentlich heutzutage sein denn computer
davon stellte den abschluss nicht
wichtige genau sie sagen es glaube ich
richtig ich glaube das internet bis 2009
grundbedürfnis geworden wie wasser strom
wärme und elektrizität
ich glaube es ist eine grundausstattung
wie fließen lassen so was früher früher
50 jahren immer da eine ferienwohnung
hatte man provinz elektrizität gab keine
steckdose und wenn man es nicht gab hat
mit dem monatlich gemietet und heute ist
es bei mir zumindest die wohnung ein
internetzugang tätig sind
es gibt aber schon darum jedem noch so
in verwinkelte hinlegen der wohnung wenn
sich gerade wirklich auch deswegen
gewählt damit abgestiegen ist aber jede
ferienwohnung die dame auf sich hält
bietet uns internet so wie wasser strom
zieht es wird einfach immer normaler
aber deutlich darauf hinweisen
diese pflichten auf digitalität müssen
natürlich auch mit dem recht zum zugang
verknüpft sein und genauso auch global
gesehen muss jede region der welt
eigentlich internet sogar haben kann
das ist glaube ich an ethisches gebot
das wirklich keine der internet lücken
gibt auf der messe das wird das internet
nicht zuviel intranets wird sind dass
diese demokratischen gedanken
unter netz der welt entspannendes wird
mein werk das ist wirklich auch realität
mit allergenen angeschlossen werden um
das netz weil das natürlich auch eine
wiesn form von selbstbestimmung hat
informationeller selbstbestimmung werden
und gute manchen regionen der welt gibt
es in dem zensur dass deutschland auch
dem gedanken des zuwider dass wir nur
dass wir wiederum stützt ist ein im
intranet und bestimmte seiten gar nicht
aufrufen jetzt durch filter usw
dass man zum beispiel jugendlicher laut
google oder jedes suchmaschine ist der
zugang so dass noch mal wieder ziemlich
die zur eigentlichen kommen und zwar das
der capital der digitalen grundrechte
der europäischen union sind initiative
sie können sich anschauen auf bild.de
stellt teil kommt view empfehle ich sehr
an wasser ist es das ist als der versuch
wird jemals digitale grundrechte
aufzustellen
der hintergrund wie vor eine gruppe von
bürgerinnen und bürgern hat 2000
einen vorschlag hat es der digitalen
grundrechte europäischen union arbeitet
er auf 5 12 2016 dem europäischen
parlament in brüssel und der
öffentlichkeit zur weiteren diskussion
übergeben will
seit der veröffentlichung der das dicke
daten digital carter vorschlags im
dezember 2016 haben uns unter den
kommentaren vorschläge zur verbesserung
und ergänzung des niveaus erreicht wir
möchten uns an dieser stelle bei allen
mitwirkenden bedanken
initiatoren der charta haben unterdessen
die vorschläge diskutiert sie werden auf
basis des gesammelten feedbacks am 25 01
eine überarbeitete fassung vorschlagen
und der allgemeinheit übergeben der text
ist ab sofort auch online auf die
weltkarte punkte youtube zu lesen
kommentieren
und das möchte ich jetzt auch mit ihnen
machen möchte ihnen jetzt diese punkte
hier vorstellen diese digitalen karte
und jedes wieder zu animieren diese
einzelartikel des unglaublich 13
auch online zu kommentieren oder anderes
gesagt wenn wir jetzt hier zu einigen
kommen der diskussion notiere ich merke
ich mir fliegen wer das sie dann unter
dem jeweiligen artikel posten
sie können nämlich unter den artikel
mitdiskutieren sie können diese artikel
selbst kommentieren
erst artikel will die würde des menschen
ist auch im digitalen zeitalter
unantastbar sie muss ihr zweck der
technischen entwicklung seien begrenzt
deren einsatz das war so das anlegen
einer des ohres digitale humanismus von
hernieder
zweitens sie können sie die vorher
unterlag events zugangs zweitens neu
gefährdung der menschen würde ergäben
sich im digitalen zeitalter insbesondere
durch big data hier steht neu
gefährdungen frage ist es ein neues
video problem in dieselbe aber big data
künstliche intelligenz vorhersagen
steuerung menschlichen verhaltens
massenüberwachung einsatz von
algorithmen robotik und menschen
erschienen schnell sowie
machtkonzentration privatunternehmen die
rechte aus dieser karte geld gegenüber
staaten stimmten ich denke hier ist
unstrittig mehr also das team die würde
des menschen natürlich auch im digitalen
zeitalter unantastbar wichtig für diesen
29 erklären könnte die ganze skala
beispiel
also stets damit den finde ich jetzt
nicht strittig freiheit
jeder hat ein recht auf freie
information und kommunikation dieses
recht ist konstitutiv für die freie
gesellschaft
es beinhaltet das recht auf nichtwissen
jetzt könnte es aber eine starke thesen
gibt es noch nicht wissen
das ist jetzt natürlich nicht nur
digitale dann verstehen sie das problem
also was tun wenn wir uns dieses recht
nicht geben
ich glaube nicht dass er bald etwas
passiert ja sonst immer so gemacht
ja dass du musst
ja aber sie kennt auch die fünf der
fahrlässigkeit
ja richtig also sie meinen wenn man
jetzt wenn man jetzt verlangen würde
dass jeder sich als erstes mal gibt es
probleme
wie weit muss man es informieren man
könnte sich prinzipiell glos informiert
dann gibt es eben szenische problem
woher weißt du dass die informationen
richtig
da gibt es probleme das impliziert in
der unterricht an dieser seine elf nicht
wissen wenn sie ja das keines mehr
ich glaube das ist aber etwas anderes
glauben hier geht es jetzt um die frage
muss ich mich im internet informieren
muss ich alle möglichen informationen
immer vor augen hat musik immer
mir aus mich weiter predigen mit mit
neuesten entwicklung usw
da würde mich auch diese information
dieser informationsflut erziehen
mithalten
müssen die kassen
den 20 der pflichtsieg zion wissen ist
eigentlich nicht wissen wer ich bin wenn
wir jetzt wissen geben würde dann würde
ich das richtig ein beklagen sind
ach so ich weiß nicht wie sie versteht
halt ich verstehe es so dass man eben
sich entziehen darf
das war diese frage mit der analogen
werden es gibt eine seltsame form von
heiko maas diese 13 punkte die wir davor
gesagt es gibt ein recht auf eine
wohnung gewählt und das sehe ich damit
verbunden also es gibt ein recht eine
besiedelung von diesem informations
kontext des internets dass ich darf mich
aus dem letzten zurück zur nächsten
ich muss nicht immer in diesen ländern
mit der informationsflut aussetzen dann
finde ich den begriff der union von
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen klaren ja
vielleicht ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen meine ethische einschätzung ist
ich glaube es gibt ein recht auf nicht
wissen
also es ist meine intervention ich
glaube müssen wir haben eine pflicht zum
wissen aber dann stellt ist natürlich
das systemische problem er kann ich
wissen was jetzt wirklich richtig ist
oder gehe ich glaube fehlt uns auf den
leib
angesprochen hatten wir auch heute in
der rechtsprechung wurde das wenn man
sich nicht informiert oder so was
ähnliches beispiel wie man medien werden
oder so was hier und habe leute dabei
und das wäre echt übel so gefährlich und
so was vielleicht ist es an der sich und
dann wird man immer noch sagen
heutzutage da hat sich jemand aber dem
wetter wirklich durchleben müssen
gemeint hätte sich dieses bisschen
anrechnung mehr
und genau so denke ich das nur weil
dieses wissen ja genau hier ist
natürlich jetzt die fragen ihrem plan
ist das eben so speziell gerichtetes
wissen in einem kontext
man kannte sich fragen was von wissen
handelt es sich das wird hier auch gar
nicht genau informiert und was zum
beispiel ist gebrauchtspielen wissen was
einfach oder informationen die einfach
nicht relevant ist und dann wären wir
punkte auf das man sagen was wenn im
anschluss und nicht relevant ist
bestimme ich natürlich lässt sich
relevanz immer am zielort am interesse
dass die person verfolgt das heißt man
muss dann ich glaube man muss es so sein
wenn ich ein interesse haben oder ein
ziel haben dann habe ich kein recht auf
nicht ist also wenn ich ein interesse
wenn ich mich orientieren der welt
nämlich auf alte
ziel nachgehen dann habe ich die pflicht
alle information über dieses ziel einzug
darf ich mich nicht verstehst wenn da
noch eine andere meinung die ich
aufnehmen müsste darf ich sie nicht
einfach ignorieren nur weil es mich
jetzt in diesem verfolgen das ziel die
tiere zum beispiel wenn jetzt im winter
nachrichten kommen war hier 30 prozent
in die gewitterwahrscheinlichkeit darf
ich den kindern wird wenn ich auf den
man glauben möchte
weil dann könnte ich zu 30 prozent in
große gefahr das heißt ich würde sagen
dass das recht auf nichtwissen gilt nur
dann wenn es nicht wissen kein interesse
betrifft also ich glaube bei uns nicht
wissen als auch ja dann ließ ich es bin
hat er das recht aufgaben also sondern
dass man ihr schreiben des nichtwissens
von köln also der begriff business und e
books und setzt es wichtig da auch
darüber kann man es glaube ich grad bei
den gibt es nicht wir sind raus haben
und auch der begriff des wissens
informationen
ich finde auffassung des gerichtes recht
auf information und kommunikation haben
als seine pflicht als kenne er auch
dieses mal nicht klar machen und dann
habe ich so viel ist sicher dann will
ich würde es anders sehen aber kümmere
dass nur die debatte stimmte wie eine
recht hat auch freie formationen der hat
einiges an den pflicht zum wissen
wirklich sagen oder dem pflicht so viele
informationen kritisch zu sich nicht als
rivale münze zum leben aber ich glaube
mir ein recht darauf hat auch eine
pflicht alles zu wissen was er wissen
könnte gesetzt hat interesse funktionen
[Musik]
tja das verstehe ich hier sollten wir
ein recht also in diesem abend wirklich
recht das möchten also es wäre dann auch
ein bisschen schneider unserer freiheit
sie haben recht als zum beispiel als es
ein wirklich guter punkt haben also ganz
spannende frage als wir kommen hier
wirklich im interesse seiner
punktgleichheit jeder mensch habe das
recht auf eine gleichberechtigte
teilhabe in der digitalen sphäre
es gilt in der europäischen
grundrechte-charta an komponierte
diskriminierungsverbot über die
verwendung von automatisierten verfahren
darf nicht dazu führen dass menschen von
zugang zu gütern dienstleister oder von
der teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen leben
ausgeschlossen werden es geht jetzt
besondere richtiges unter dem schutz vor
einigen tagen lebensrisiken recht auf
arbeit recht auf
auf bewegungsfreiheit und justiz und
polizei
ich denke das betrifft den teilhabern
digitalen sphäre der digitale screens
nicht direkt definiert dass die digitale
sphäre ist diskussions bedürftig es
würde ich jetzt zb gerne er in der
diskussion voran einschreiten also ich
werde es heute geboren ende werde ich
auf die idee jakarta com video gehen und
werde die ergebnisse die wir jetzt hier
haben derart kommentare ein tipp das zu
kommentieren dürfen sie gerne auch
machen selbst digitale karte punkt
million artikel 4 wieder an äußerer
sicherheit
er ist im digitalen zeitalter werden
ihre äußere sicherheit auf neue weise
bedroht
bei der ausgegangen der
schutzverantwortung des staates sind
länge rechtsstaatliche grenzen zu
beachten
zweitens sicherheitsbehörden dürfen
nicht nicht auf durch private der gruppe
daten zugreifen
ausnahmen sind nur auf gesetzliche
grundlagen zum schutz besonders wichtige
rechtsgüter zulässig
drittens eine anlasslose maßen
nicht statt viertens waffensystem
interview nicht voll automatisiert
eingesetzt ich will jetzt auch noch mal
durch geben ich möchte in den baum sechs
jahren mehr diskutiert wir haben eine so
witzige fünf meinung sein
jeder hat das recht der digitalen welt
seine meinung frei zu äußern
eine zensur findet nicht statt wie
youtube oder youtube und facebook
jetzt gibt es aber heike maßnahmen
sondern diese diese dieses gesetz
geworden dass man jetzt da wenn wir das
umsetzen
genau das würde jetzt dem so ein
bisschen das könnte man zum beispiel mal
drunter stadt wie sie zum diesem neuen
gesetz geäußert
facebook wird jetzt richtet gewissen
hate speech sache nachzugehen
bei hey schau mal wieder die frage ist
hält freie meinungsäußerung oder ist es
nicht einfach eine ein um eine formlose
nordischen etwas justitia books also
digitale hält es im ok sowie aktivitäten
die geeignet sind den hof oder die uns
person ernsthaft zu gefährden sind zu
verhindern ja also wo ist die grenze
zwischen freier meinungsäußerung und
ex-politikerin korrektes thema aber das
problem ist ja auch nicht richtig fertig
das ist ein ding das der das neue logo
fragestunde
das betrifft die meinungsfreiheit
gewahrt
natürlich ist jeder punkt im digitalen
können wir viel anonymer und siemens
meine äußerst glaube ich schon
und auch viel und durch diesen aber
zeitlosigkeit sind wir auch geneigt
brutaler vielleicht oder problematische
mit uns und unsere freien meinungs- und
glaubensfreiheit diskurs mann ist sicher
zu stellen
staatliche stellen und die betreiber von
informations und kommunikations diensten
sind verpflichtet für die einhaltung von
apsis 132 vorfall vorverlegt durch
dadurch stellen oder privatesten
aufgesetzt und
wir zusätzlich einbringen
jeder das recht nicht objekt für
automatisieren entscheidung von
erheblicher bedeutung für die
lebensführung zu sein sofern
automatisierte verfahren zur
beeinträchtigung führen besteht offene
legen überprüfung und entscheidungen
durch ein mensch die kritisierte
entscheidungen sind offen zu legen das
finde ich auch wieder produkte
insbesondere bei der verarbeitung von
massendaten sind anonymisierung und
transparenz zu stärken
wenn auch sehr sind künstliche
intelligenz jetzt hat die 80 normativ
entscheidungen können nur von menschen
getroffen werden die einsatz und
entwicklung von künstlicher intelligenz
in grundrechts relevanten bereichen muss
gesellschafters begleitet und vom
gesetzgeber reguliert für die handlungen
selbst längere maschinen und die daraus
resultierende folgen muss immer eine
natürliche oder juristische person
antwort ist bei infrastruktur die für
das funktionieren der gesellschaft für
essenziell sind muss staatliche
kontrolle und krisenvorsorge
gewährleistet
spannend finde ich jetzt hier artikel
diese diese verantwortung die
verantwortung also bei künstlicher
intelligenz stelle sich die frage wer
ist jetzt dafür fand für den algorithmus
zu eröffnen wenn die gute punkt der
programmier oder derjenigen diejenigen
die intelligenz 1 setzt natürlich alles
immer schön intelligent schließung oder
hier hat auch noch keine juristische
personen zum beispiel jetzt nicht eine
individuelle mensch sind zum beispiel
eine institution wie die lmu münchen
die kann auch wenn man die dinge zur
verantwortung gezogen die informationen
staatliche stellen müssen öffentlich zu
wenig da sind transparenzgebot gilt auch
gegenüber privaten sofern diese über
informationen verfügen die freiheits
wirklichen betroffenen veranstaltung
bedeutet sie für unversehrtheit der
wohnung
jeder hat das recht in seiner wohnung
und beobachter zu leben
klar als ich dafür keine drogen keine
spionin keine webcams installieren hat
und dann hier im livestream aus der
privatwohnung machen diesen das wird
auch das ist natürlich ein alter punkt
dessen grundrecht der
privatsphäre und datenschutz und daten
sogar jeder hat das recht auf den schutz
seiner daten und achtung seien peanuts
wenn jeder das recht seine daten selbst
bestimmt den sohn bezogenen daten
personen nach treu und glauben und für
feste ziele erhoben und verarbeitet
werden wenn dies wird das jeweilige
nutzungsverhalten es erforderlich ist
und eine vorherige einwilligung gefolgt
ist und auf gesetzliche kultur die
einwilligung muss ausdrücklich und
informiert erfolg nutzungsverhältnisse
müssen fair und transparent gestaltet
haben die einhaltung dieser rechte wird
und unabhängige stimmen gibt es so was
wie eine unheimliche stimmung anbieter
von diensten oder produkten dürfen wir
uns solche daten erheben und verarbeiten
welche für den zweck der benutzung
erforderlich die grundsätze von privacy
by design plattform zum einzug
und wenn man zumindest um ihre
selbstbestimmung und unversehrtheit
vertraulichkeit und integrität
informationstechnischer systeme mit ist
sicher zu stellen jeder hat ein recht
auf verschlüsselung seiner daten
ich würde auch sagen eine arbeitspflicht
auch also selbst dafür zu sorgen dass
seine daten sicher sind das ist so viel
wie medienkompetenz
ich wollte medienkompetenz doch dieses
dieser begriffe medienkompetenz würde
hinzufügen
jeder habe die pflicht medienkompetenz
zu erlangen und selbst sich zu schützen
daten sich jeder ein recht auf
datensicherheit
von dem informations technischen system
und der sie verarbeitet daten meist
höchstmöglichen schutz zu gewährleisten
mit der intel sleep stelle des
bildschirms hin zu bekämpfen
also was mir fehlt es in den pflichten
klar dass jetzt rechte kann mir fehlen
hier den pflichten tugenden die wir in
der es während der digitalität
entwickeln müssen wir müssen selbst
dafür sorgt ersten zu tragen
geschützt sind wir müssen selbst uns
darum können wir dürfen nicht immer nur
einmal antritt
das vorwerfen verneint wir müssen selbst
bestimmt auch mit unseren daten umgehen
waren das rechnet wahlen und
abstimmungen teil zu dem punkt darf
nicht an den zugang zu digitalen medien
gebunden sei das ist eine spannende
frage ich sagen die 20 jahren mag man
über diesen 25 jahren reicht man das ist
so wie wenn wir heute sagen würden ich
möchte aber mit der dampflokomotive nach
berlin muss im gc ist jetzt also ich
glaube er wird durch in 20 jahren gibt
es dieses rechtliche obwohl natürlich es
können fürs könnte personen geben die so
eingestellt sind
das sind dazu in der lage sind aber ich
glaube bis dahin während der digital
möglichkeiten so einfach so zu gewinnen
dass das eine große erleichterung dass
es menschen gibt denen dieser umgang
probleme bereitet von ver einschränkung
aber ich kann mir nicht vor
medien der einstellung digitale medien
sind hinter reden immer durch
erleichterung des verfahrens heißt es
kein freier zugang jeder mensch hat das
recht auf freie gleiche und anonymen
zugang zu kommunikationsdiensten ohne
dafür auf grundlegende rechte verzichten
zu müssen
das internet ist bestandteil der grund
fassung sagte ich strom wasser
elektrizität werden jeder hat das recht
auf eine wichtige analysierte nutzung
und digitalen angebote im netz
neutralität letzten neutralität ist zu
gewährleisten
es geht auch verdienste die den zugang
zu digitalen sphäre vermitteln qualität
und wettbewerb und der digitalen welt
sind uralt und kulturelle vielfalt zu
gewährleisten
offene standards hin zu fördern macht
missbräuchliches verhalten des wirksam
zu verhindern
recht auf vergessen werden dass wenn ich
mit der spannendste jeder mensch hat das
recht auf digitalen neu anfangen dieses
recht findet seine grenzen in den
richtigen informationsinteresse
ermöglicht
schauen sie so was glaube ich gibt es so
ein problem gibt es nicht
in der analogen welt plant das problem
dass die mir fixiert werden können und
nicht mehr vergessen werden können ich
glaube die analoge welt weil sich zwei
ist geprägt vom vergessen werden weil
sie der zeitlichkeit aus sind aber nicht
hier in ihrer gewisse zeit im raum
süßigkeit des internets können die
informationen wieder herstellen sie
kennen alle diese steinbeck maschinen in
dänemark sie können schnappschüsse von
verschiedenen internetseiten waren die
schon seit 20 jahren gelöscht sind teile
ich meine ersten versuche im internet
sitzung wieder zu finden
ich sag ihnen aber nicht die adresse
besonders schutzbedürftige personen
kinder heranwachsende benachteiligte und
genießen digitalen speziellen schutz
ihre teilhabe an der digitalen wird es
für bildung jeder hat ein recht auf
bildung
die ein selbstbestimmtes leben der
digitalen welt ermöglicht vitalisierung
ist eine elementare bildung des
herausforderers sie besitzt einen
zentralen stellenwert in dem label
öffentliche bildungseinrichtung
spannende frage ich würde es auch damit
auch hier bei diesem artikel 20 gab es
jetzt eine recht rege diskussion ein
jahr in der folie immer jetzt hat
nämlich ein nutzer geschrieben der
zweite glaube ich hier in der dritte und
der vierte bei bildungsmedien in der
schonung vorschule zum beispiel
schulbücher auf digitalisierung
verzichtet werden begründung vermeide
mit digitaler jugend demenz hier sind
digitale demenz also das wäre auch ein
wunder punkt können sie gerne
diskutieren welches ermutigen hier
wirklich stellung zu nehmen kommentare
frage inwiefern sollen schüler geschützt
werden gibt es für eine frühe
frühkindliche erziehung ein
man könnte am ende dafür finden weitere
entwicklung eben auch haptische momente
voraussetzt kindern damit das gehirn
sich entwickeln müssen begreifen müssen
drei und sind ausgesetzt seien
ich glaube auch nicht dass es heißt es
nicht auch digitale ja schon ein leben
nicht mehr ausschließen es geht um die
vermischung die verquickung von
digitaler und analoger technik wenn
kinder sehr früh mit allen möglichen
dingen umgeht lernen also mit haptischer
spielen greifen formen aber auch in
tablets
ich glaube das ist der punkt man sollte
es nicht auch gegeneinander ausspielen
arbeit überspringe ich im materialgüte
stimmen und so fort also schauen sie mal
rein ist nun sie wirklich hier gibt es
eine ganz große diskussion wir sind noch
ganz am anfang
nächster sitzung die seit er 2007 von 16
bis 18 uhr raum erzeugt 14 thema
kulturen politik der digitalität wir
knüpfen direkt an diese partie genau an
dies konnten wir noch mal und schauen
auch die von krieg und geben rückblick
auf die gesamte seminar diskussion und
wünschen ein schönes muss